fino a non molto tempo fa se mi avessero
chiesto
watson che cos'è watson chi e watson mi
sarebbe venuto in mente elementare
elementare watson
poi mi sarebbe venuto in mente forse
emma watson la bella attrice combattente
mi piace lei che faceva hermione in
harry potter
poi ho scoperto che conan doyle nel suo
nei suoi libri di sherlock holmes non fa
mai dire elementare watson a sherlock
holmes watson come noi sappiamo oggi è
un computer ma è un computer niente
affatto elementare un computer molto
speciale molto particolare è un computer
che comunica non è tra i più competenti
computer che ci sono sulla terra però è
molto molto intelligente comunica con
noi
servendosi del nostro linguaggio
naturale cioè del linguaggio con cui io
adesso sto comunicando con voi con
linguaggio umano
sì un po come siri un po come se lui
risponde solo che ha un computer molto
molto molto particolare molto
intelligente perché rispondendo impara
capisce apprende è dunque si evolve a si
chiama watson semplicemente perché
l'inventore del ibm si chiamava thomas
jane watson
allora la domanda che ha messo orge
drammatiche e dopo dopo che i computer
avranno appreso si saranno evoluti dopo
che cosa sarà di noi chi ne sarà qui a
raccontarsela su questa terra
ora anche il linguaggio umano noi
l'abbiamo appreso i paleontologi ci
dicono che è un'acquisizione per noi
esseri umani relativamente recente anzi
il recentissimo perché al massimo di
sale a circa 150 mila anni fa
considerato che la nostra storia
evolutiva copre 6 milioni di anni
l'abbiamo appreso a parlare l'altro ieri
però però quando abbiamo appreso il
linguaggio che se vogliamo è proprio un
passaggio tecnologico
ecco la nostra civiltà da quel momento
da quel momento ha subito una
progressiva e forse inarrestabile
accelerazione ora senza entrare nel
ginepraio della linguistica delle
neuroscienze della neurofisiologia il
linguaggio
è quel sistema quella struttura per cui
un essere umano pensa ma soprattutto è
consapevole di pensare a coscienza di
ciò che pensa
il linguaggio è una somma di strumenti
limitata suoni parole che possono
combinarsi quindi insieme di strumenti
finiti che possono combinarsi in maniera
infinita infinita ora all'infinito ora
se io parlo del concetto di infinito un
computer mi va in tilt
ma non soltanto dal punto di vista del
linguaggio naturale ma anche con
linguaggio matematico e allora a questo
punto perché ci sono un po di cose che
il computer è ancora non sanno fare
non hanno anche se imparano anche se
evolvono non hanno imparato a fare
alcune cose sostanziali non hanno
imparato per esempio a ridere a piangere
non provano piacere non trovano dolore e
dunque non hanno ancora imparato a fare
arte a fare poesia per noi ridere
piangere fare poesia è generare per il
computer e al massimo sono degli errori
degli errori tra cui ci viene o siberia
e poi possono fare bellissime immagini
ma non ne sono consapevoli possono
produrre bellissimi suoni ma non ne sono
consapevoli
ci viene in aiuto qui un ragazzo un
ragazzo di 21 anni che si chiama giacomo
è un ragazzo che però è di 200 anni fa
leopardi nel 1819 a 21 anni e scrive una
poesia che ha veramente ha davvero una
bella presente una poesia che ha la
pretesa di essere una poesia sulla
poesia cioè sulla capacità del
linguaggio umano di concepire cioè di
trattenere dentro di sé e quindi di
generare e di percepire di attraversare
l'infinito una bella preside tesa e la
cosa straordinaria è che lui ci riesce
eccola qua questa è la poesia italiana
più nota al mondo la più tradotta la più
conosciuta
io adesso
voglio provare a dimostrare che grazie
anche al contributo di questa poesia che
noi siamo arrivati a creare qualche
tempo dopo il linguaggio dei computer il
linguaggio dei computer
certo è certo è sempre caro mi fu
quest'ermo colle la poesia
ma che cos'è la poesia è in italiano
questa io ci voglio provare e la mia
lingua madre è l'italiano io sono
un'attrice i miei strumenti sono la voce
e il corpo
quindi io voglio provare a farvi sentire
l'infinito perlomeno quello dentro
nelle parole di leopardi la poesia è
qualcosa di molto particolare in cui la
parola del linguaggio umano risuona a
risonanza nel nostro linguaggio naturale
quotidiana alla questa risonanza non è
così rilevante nella poesia la parola
diventa carne viva la verità delle
parole non passa per noi attraverso è un
concetto difficile questo dell'ariston
aree la verità non passa attraverso il
senso soltanto attraverso il sesso ma
prima di tutto passa attraverso il corpo
pulsante la carne viva che è il suono è
questo che ci passa verità perché per
noi noi per pronunciare dei suoni
dobbiamo muovere il corpo e quindi i
nostri muscoli che sono atti a muovere
il tratto vocale ad articolare il nostro
respiro compiono un movimento che di per
se stesso è già molto significante
faccio un esempio se io pronuncia una a
io devo aprire la bocca al massimo grado
quindi quando dirò molte a mi si
riempirà di apertura verso in
particolare la poesia prende questo la
poesia si occupa di questo e allora e
allora proviamo a leggerla proviamo a
sentire a capire questa poesia ce la
facciamo magari leggere da watson sempre
caro mi fu quest'ermo colle in questa
siepe che da tanta parte dell'ultimo
orizzonte il guardo esclude ma sedendo e
mirando interminati spazi di là da
quella e sovrumani silenzi e
profondissima quiete io nel pensier mi
fingo ove per poco il corno ansys paura
è come il vento oddo stormir tra queste
piante io quello infinito silenzio a
questa voce vo comparando e mi sovviene
l'eterno e le morte stagioni e la
presenta è viva e il suon di lei
così tra questa immensità s'annega il
pensier mio e il naufragar m'è dolce in
questo mare alla rotatoria prendere la
seconda uscita
la cosa bella è che lei non sa di aver
fatto una battuta ci fa ridere è già una
grande cosa ma lei non ride ma guardate
non ha letto malissimo e se avessi fatto
l'esperimento che si chiamato qualcuno
di noi diciamo di no per non dire di voi
a leggerlo e avreste letto così perché
questo è un po quello che già come vuole
ci vuole
però ci riserva anche delle belle
sorprese che c'è il potere della poesia
proviamo ad analizzarla questa poesia
proviamo aperti il plot narrativo lo
conosciamo tutti la situazione narrativa
è molto semplice c'è un ragazzo che c'è
una passione andare in cima a una
collina guardare il paesaggio ma non gli
piace guardarlo dietro una siepe così
che lui chiude gli occhi si siede e si
immagina infiniti mondi spazi
interminabili poi questa cosa un po lo
turba perché la realtà aumentata per
giacom non era un problema è il ritorno
della sua realtà presente scopre che
quella esperienza che aveva fatto
cosmica comunque anche e soprattutto
nasce qui tra queste cose è dentro la
realtà reale che il suo corpo tocca e a
questo punto non può che naufragare
dolcemente perché si deve lasciare
andare a questo infinito che pervade
tutto detta così non è la stessa cosa di
come detta qui a e allora guardiamo come
è detta inizia con sempre inizia non
tanto col concetto di sempre che a me
non interessa molto in questo caso
inizia con una s
se noi stringiamo i denti facciamo
viaggiare il nostro fiato attraverso i
denti se avessimo la respirazione
circolare che hanno certi musicisti
potremo arrivare all'infinito stelle
suoni spazio sempre la è sempre la è
diversamente dalla come abbiamo visto
prima la è costringe la mia il mio
tratto vocale la mia bocca ad
articolarsi in una fessura si chiude un
po di più però questa chiusura mi
consente di allargare il lateralità sé e
quindi lei è proprio la lettera del mio
animo che si mette in stato di
contemplazione di osservazione e di ciò
che è davanti a sempre ci sono due e in
prima battuta che io devo pronunciare se
incorpora la poesia se la pronuncia voce
alta vedete che sempre viene poi
rafforzato subito dopo da siete quel
sempre e la siepe siete e poi abbiamo di
nuovo un rafforzamento sedendo sedendo
ecco allora sempre caro siete sedendo
questo ragazzo si siede avete presente
vi ricordate come il giacomo è tuttora
tradito c'è la gobba ea non ha un corpo
proprio felice e si siede con fatica e
però questa situazione gli consente
qualcosa il suo corpo di veramente unico
forse per questo gli piace di
snocciolare vertebra dopo vertebra la
sua spina dorsale sta come in posizione
yoga non pronuncia un no ma
semplicemente perché deve pronunciare un
che li tirerà sulla spina dorsale guarda
sedendo e mirando interminati spazi di
là da quelle sovrani silenzi e
profondissima quiete
io nel pensier mi fingo hop e per poco
devo andare veloce non ho il tempo
potrei ragionare su ogni suono che c'è
in questo testo leopardi queste cose le
faceva coscientemente perché conosceva i
linguaggi umani conosceva l'ebraico
conosceva il greco conosceva il latino
conosceva il francese ove per poco il
corno si spaura
io quando dobbiamo esprimere degli dei
sentimenti noi parliamo per vocali
perché la vocale è quella che appena
appena noi dobbiamo semplicemente aprire
e chiudere non plasmiamo la realtà
semplicemente esce il nostro fiato
e guardate il primo emistichio cosa fa
il buon giacomo sempre caro mi fu le
mette tutti sentimenti umani nel prima
mysterio nel primo verso lui diceva bene
parleremo di tutti i sentimenti umani
siamo nell'infinito figuriamoci
e allora nella prima parte abbiamo
questo corpo che si allarga
ma poi va in verticale chiude gli occhi
e poi tutte queste o sono tutte
esperienze che sono inferiori e poi c'è
la paura
devo andare veloce nella seconda parte
c'è una versione quella di firenze dove
lui fa delle piccole modifiche sono
rilevanti per farci capire i cambiamenti
le intenzioni modo stormir tra queste
piante c'è scritto fra queste piante lui
fa una croce davanti e mette tra ci
teneva che al posto della ci fosse una
dentale nella dentale la lingua batte
contro i denti la lingua batte dove il
dente duole
il suono della dental e puntuale quindi
con la dentale noi diciamo tube la
realtà tangibile oggettiva odo stormir
tra queste piante questa realtà io
quello infinito e va bene e poi c'è un
naufragio
devo superare questa ecco questi sono i
suoni sono suoni però che sono carne
sono muscoli sono sangue della poesia
però voglio portarvi più avanti perchè
c'è un'altra parte altrettanto
interessante sconvolgente per me è che è
quella della struttura ossea della
poesia e forse del sistema nervoso
allora la nostra generosa lettrice ha
eletto come leggerebbero tutti perché
giacomo ci inganna usa questa poesia per
fare una narrazione molto molto
elementare e usa molto bene verso e la
punteggiatura primo verso sempre caro mi
fu quest'ermo colle virgola tutto quello
che voglio dire si esprime dentro il
verso secondo verso e questa siepe
virgola che da tanta parte il senso del
verso non finisce nel verso ma con una
figura retorica che si chiama in john
brennan
io e il verso lo vado apre il senso del
verso la vado a precipitare nel verso
successivo
e questa siepe virgola che dà tanta pace
dell'ultimo orizzonte il guardo esclude
e qui finisce il verso ma sedendo e
mirando virgola interminati spazi di là
da quella virgola e sovrumani silenzi e
profondissima quiete
io nel pensier mi fingo ove per poco il
corno si spaura è come il vento
odo stormir tra queste piante
io quello infinito silenzio a questa
voce
vo comparando e mi sovvien l'eterno e le
morte stagioni e la presente e viva e il
suon di lei
così tra questa immensità s'annega il
pensier mio e il naufragar m'è dolce in
questo mare
ecco qui lui ci fa precipitare di là ci
crea quest'altro spazio che adesso
potrebbe essere bianco e ci dice io non
te lo posso ti posso portare per mano
verso l'infinito tc faccio cascare che
ci faccio naufragare di là sta di là
nasce qui è tra queste parole è nel
finito nel non finito l'infinito ma si
mettano sono lì che sono a fianco e si
intersecano
io non so si può dire che qui c'è il
corpo qui c'è il pensiero si può dire
che qua c'è il finito qua c'è l'infinito
ci può dire che questo è uno e questo 0
sì forse si può dire anche questo
sicuramente sono più intrecciate in
giacomo sicuramente giacomo come vi
dicevo non ha bisogno di realtà
aumentata ma sicuramente giacomo ci ha
aiutato ad arrivare poi a affrontare il
problema del linguaggio anche in
relazione al problema del linguaggio
dell'intelligenza artificiale
ora giacomo leopardi non era sicuramente
un uomo felice anzi decisamente era un
uomo infelice e non nutriva neanche
troppa fiducia nelle progressive sorti
umani
ma sia scritto questa poesia e poi non
l'ha stracciata
io credo che non avesse intenzione di
tormentare i nostri anni di scuola ma
aveva fiducia in qualcosa aveva fiducia
nella parola aveva paura fiducia nella
del suono aveva fiducia nel linguaggio
ed è proprio questo linguaggio ma
linguaggio di che qualità di che qualità
corporea di che qualità umana di quake
carte questo linguaggio e la catena che
lega gli umani nello spazio tempo io mi
commuovo molto devo dirvi quando faccio
questo lavoro sull'infinito io sento
giacomo qui lo sento qui e il suo
linguaggio di così alta qualità
attraversa la trama dello spazio tempo e
come un linguaggio a quattro dimensioni
4 dice un film che ha tentato di
spiegare questa cosa si chiama drive è
un film di fantascienza dove questi
alieni che naufragano veneti consegnano
linguaggio tutto tondo alla linguista lo
consegnano certamente il prezzo è alto
per questo viaggio cosmico e un
naufragio è un prezzo ma è anche un dono
è un dono
se il naufragio e nell'infinito il
contatto è cosmico
ora hai la masca detto il fondatore di
tesla che fra 30 anni saremo per metà al
cyborg
io non lo so se sulla terra tra 30 anni
e watson sapranno fare questo naufragio
sapranno apprendere a naufragare
beh allora me non importerà molto se
sulla terra saremo uomini cyborg o
computer che usano linguaggio umano per
il momento questo lo sappiamo fare solo
noi
e allora il mio invito cosmico è
godiamocela la poesia grazie
grazie
[Musica]